of the drop-off
what's the play unity
just follow my lead
uncharted 4 is a powerful game about
loss betrayal
regret and redemption in both its
momentous set pieces and its intimate
personal moments Uncharted 4 drives its
narrative forward with a rare
understanding of its characters its
world and the gameplay tying them all
together it's a stunning combination of
disparate parts it's a breathtaking
marvel of a game by this point in the
series developer Naughty Dog has led us
across the globe in search of famous
treasures from equally famous legends in
uncharted 4 however we find protagonist
Nathan Drake leading a quiet life with
freelance journalist Elena Fisher who
also happens to be his wife they live in
New Orleans they have a three-bedroom
house they play video games together but
this all changes with the return of
Nathan's older brother Sam who was
thought to be dead for 15 years not only
is he alive and well but he also has a
lead on one of history's greatest
treasures the loot of the pirate Henry
Avery which the brothers have sought
since their early days of treasure
hunting as with previous titles
uncharted 4 revolves around third-person
combat climbing and puzzle solving but
unlike its predecessors this game often
lets you sneak past enemy soldiers
without doing any harm at all
stealth requires a more patient measured
approach but it feeds into the idea of a
more reserved Nathan as does the fact
that you don't always have to kill
anyone here unless you want to uncharted
fours action has a symbiotic
relationship with its story there are
minor mechanical problems the cover
system can send you to the wrong
obstacle or wall in the middle of
firefights and rarely Nathan will grab
the wrong ledge when climbing but these
observations wash away within the grand
scheme of things there's always
something incredible around the corner
to erase the momentary annoyances
in terms of structure uncharted for
embraces a more open approach with much
of its level design there are small sand
boxes where you climb towers learn the
layout mark enemies and choose to fight
through them or circumvent the group
entirely these areas were hurt the pace
of a lesser game but uncharted 4 keeps
tension alive even in its calculated
moments transitioning from open areas to
action sequences without halting the
momentum and speaking of Uncharted
forest set pieces are the best in the
series and among the best coordinated
stunts in the medium just when you think
Uncharted forum might settle into a
steady rhythm it throws something new at
you with high velocity and incredible
power these sequences give you agency
but also enough guidance to maintain the
euphoric rush of a car chase without
constantly dying
uncharted 4 directs you with its camera
and lighting and also audio cues
characters shout over the din of gunfire
telling you when to fight or when to
just keep running the dialogue makes
sense within the moment everything just
feels and sounds right and then there's
the presentation of it all the
cinematography both in game and during
cutscenes it amplifies the wonder of
this gorgeous world there's also
stunning animation at play and it sets a
new watermark for games in the way it
can illustrate subtle emotions like
distrust or yearning uncharted 4 is
multiplayer though ditches grounded
storytelling in favor of all-out chaos
you can use what are called mystical x'
or artifacts with supernatural abilities
that are taken from throughout the
series you can also summon AI snipers
and medics to aid your team's efforts
uncharted 4 is multiplayer exhibits the
necessary creativity to elevate its
already fluid third-person mechanics but
although the multiplayer works well and
it features a progression system that
can keep you playing past your first few
matches it's not the primary draw
lady singing the lure of uncharted 4 is
in its remarkable single-player journey
how each of its parts feeds into the
same cohesive whole
uncharted 4 bounces between set pieces
and personal moments with such grace
with such skill and poise and affection
for its characters that you don't mind
when the gun stop firing and the smoke
clears and Nathan gets a moment to
breathe yes this is a thrilling
adventure through exotic locations with
spectacular action sequences and a
pacing that pulls you through with ease
I had a smile on my face the moment it
began but it's also a story about family
it's a story about self-examination and
most of all as its final moments make
clear this is a story about storytelling
the importance we lend our idols legends
and myths how we pass down the ones that
inspire us in its writing in its design
and its understanding of what makes
games unique uncharted 4 is something to
aspire to
it's a shining example and we'll be
talking about it for years to come
ah what
why are you I'm in here being stabbed
with a fork